here's just some general Insanity of the
day I think there is a trans genocide
okay and I think it's you okay because
you're sterilizing a lot of these people
uh removal of the gonads in the uterus
is an absolute sterilization and then
puberty blockers have a very high rate
uh and uh cross-ex hormones have
extremely high rate of sterilizing the
individual so these people can no longer
reproduce that's genocide is this the
joke you can go for a joke you are
removing these people's ability to
reproduce like for instance Jazz
Jennings can never have kids jazz
Jennings also can't actually feel any
said like sexual uh feeling of any kind
why are you what stranger's genital
pleasure that's so weird I'm not doing
anything I'm not a doctor Tim I don't
believe you do this right I support
people having access to health care of
course let's try again you seem scared
of this I don't want to keep talking
about someone's genital pleasure who's a
stranger things